okay okay Moscow homie told I don't know
the name okay let's play some Queens
gambit against him I cannot pronounce
the name I'm sorry so what is this it's
a very strange kind of Catalan opening
early night to see three hmm well you
can take on c5 still maybe and play this
ending no wow okay hmm can I keep this
pawn on c4 it's a bit greedy but let's
see if I can try to keep this
and I can make play some D 5
hmm i don't like Knight a5 here okay
let's just develop him if it takes you
four I mean this is taken a long time
and in the meantime I've got my pieces
developed to two active squares so
shouldn't be too bad um okay what's now
it's not so easy to play a move here
Night Moves sb7 hanging
with some general improving don't know
where to go
oh that's that's nice I mean okay I
understand the point is now trading to
some ending way is better but at least
that makes my development much easier
don't think this is bad my development
is far too good for being yeah I cannot
be worse yes what I'm trying to say with
that good that good of a development so
I can be five or something like that
yeah 492 it's not easy route is if I
meant to play some some decent meals
okay i still have that and i also have
h5 asking them about a good position for
the Queen maybe you for is that position
okay still I can also check and see I
don't really have a great continuation
down
whoopsie for is a seasonal but that's
not it so clear what this threatens ok
checker doesn't work
huh he's got queenie form
yes but
it's not thick tacky oh okay after I
have to do that probably it's kind of
kind of disappointing but probably have
to do this now probably had something
better the development was so strong
that it felt like I should have
something to give me some kind of
advantage
i wonder if i can really safely take on
c1 and on be too because of pins on the
e-file could be an issue hmm that could
be an issue I can maybe I can go just
back okay look let's see what is what is
playing I'm I'm thinking push-up f3e but
you never know
and that really such a difficult
decision to d5 okay I wants to go into
the seventh hmm that makes an awful lot
of sense okay I really don't I mean the
poorness it's nice good but it's more
important that um I prevent it by going
on the seventh it's really really the
more important thing yeah he wants to go
look you one I guess
position is rather draw ish but I'm
somewhat be rent on time
i'm not sure but ok but i have no i
don't have the time to figure it out
completely time morning Carol traders as
an immediate roar check
I'm getting this point I think makes
life a lot easier okay I'm not getting
the pole 5.rar offered you that you have
to decline her head it is completely
gone now so what about this yam isn't
there something here yeah okay 92 is
clearly better yeah the engine just
wants to win the porno well I saw that
but hmm yeah I still I still should do
that it felt a little bit now at age
five was wasn't really good yeah I have
to be of take take what what you can do
and Here I am better i mean not sure
that I can do something but something
like this you can you can try to win at
least got a pawn this way yeah he takes
I just planted the night in one move we
can take the night oh my goodness ah you
can just take the night can you believe
that and he took there oh wow hey one
sec was immensely lucky okay here i feel
pretty sure that next drawing chances
should be should be quite good yeah yes
it is a draw way that was very lucky he
can just take the night there in one
move Oh God okay well thanks for
watching